and chair of the Derby and darish
integrated care board and this will very
useful W it Le uh me to know how the
district can help the NHS work together
in improving health and well-being of
the residents in our district we also
been meeting regularly with all of the
leaders uh and CEOs in the D in darish
looking at setting up a strategic
leadership team for the new combined
Authority uh and I'm believe there'll be
a full report at the next Council as we
progress with that so that's me thank
you
chair thank you Council Barker so uh
item six uh public participation well
the no questions have been submitted
under procedure rule number eight for
this meeting so item seven is the review
of polling districts and polling places
so I'm going to uh ask Mr hickin to
explain the report don't
you thank you chair so the purpose of
this report today is to set out
proposals for consideration and approval
of the provision of polling districts
and polling places within Northeast
arire District Council
area you may be aware that electoral
Services uh Team review all polling
places before and after each ele ction
to ensure that they remain suitable for
use and you may also be aware that there
have been other recent
reviews in recent times for polling
places to meet different requirements
such as covid for instance where we had
to ensure electors could maintain social
distancing and more recently polling
plac has changed for the May 2023
elections due to the new requirements of
the elections Act 2022 you'll recall the
accessibility and the need to have
separate areas for electors to show
their photo
identification in private for example uh
were put in
place this formal review however that
this report concerns itself with has
been undertaken in line with statutory
requirements as the report explains we
have a window of around 16 months
between 1st of October and 31st of
January 2025 to carry this work
out in essence the reviews seek to
ensure that all electors have reasonable
facilities for voting as far as is
reasonably practicable including those
electors who may have one or more
disability or access
issues the review is a function of the
council and not the Electoral
registration officer or returning
officer and therefore this report is
before c Council for consideration
presented by myself as managing
director in undertaking this review a
notice of review was published on the
2nd of October which commenced the
consultation period consules included
electors councilors MPS parish and town
councils political parties existing po
polling place contacts and others as the
acting returning officer makes comments
on the consultation responses the
responses have been split across two
parliamentary constituencies that
Northeast derer covers the acting
returning officer B bals over confirmed
that they happy with the proposals
within the closing dates for the
responses was 30th of
October we received a total of 15
responses or
submissions 10 of these were opposed to
using one of the existing polling
stations clearly in an Ideal World
electoral administrators would have the
choice of a range of fully accessible
buildings conveniently located for
electors in the area this is not always
possible though depending on what other
premises are
nearby in the case of Park House primary
schools submissions were received not to
use the school with alternative premises
suggested the Pavilion and a couple all
the pre private premises uh put
forward the Pavilion would be an ideal
polling station but at the previous
statutory review concerns were raised
that it's simply too far away from the
main residential area of the
electors during this review it has been
acknowledged that a move away from the
school would be beneficial so that the
school can remain open as usual on
polling day the private premises
unfortunately cannot accommodate us on
polling day but if things change in the
future we'll look at this again subject
to approval of the final proposal
schedule it will be necessary to publish
a revised schedule of polling districts
and polling places together with the
relevant maps and with that chair the
recommendations are set out at the front
of this report and I'm happy to take any
questions thank you are there any
comments or
questions Council gillet chair I was one
of the people who objected to the use of
Park House school but I want to thank
the officers who conducted the review I
I see the difficulties that they have
discussed in the report and I expected
those difficulties but I welcome those
comments and in particular I welcome the
commitment to review it as and when
alternative premises come on become
available as well thank
you any
others if not we move to the
recommendations so we need a
proposer yeah I sorry I can move there
thank you and a second
please thank you Council Barry so we're
going to move to the vote then so
um our first chance to test them
out vote now oh no it sounds
like I think that concludes the voting
so if we could see the
the result
please overwhelmingly carried thank
you so it toate then the treasury
management update so report of the
Deputy leader of the council so Council
carry over to you
please thank you this is to update the
Council on the treasury management
activities for the period April to
September
23 SI for ref rised treasury management
code has made some changes to the
reporting requirements from April the
council has for many years received half
yearly updates and this will continue
but the information that is required to
be reported under the code has changed
this is reflected in the report you have
received today you will note in the
report that there are no compliance
matters or risks to raise at this time
and I move that the council notes the
Tre treasury management activities
undertaken During the period April to
September 2023 as outlined in appendix 1
thank you chair thank you before I ask
are you seconding Council can I second
that sorry thank you seconded so are
there any comments or
questions it's been moved and seconded
then so let's move to the
vote
enoy see that concludes the voting so
let's see the final result which should
be a shock thank you that's unanimous
thank you that's
carried so item nine then changes to the
Constitution which relates to the
speaking at planning committee so I'm
going to ask Mr Sternberg to speak to
the report
please thank you
chair as some members may recall Council
asked standards committee to reconsider
the speaking at planning committee and
the limitation on the number of speakers
standards committee has been through a
review it has considered what other
neighboring councils do and just to
remind everyone there is no limit on
written reps this only relates to
speaking at the planning committee
itself the report sets out the detail of
the review and it also sets out the
changes proposed in to the relevant
Constitution rules and see paragraph 2.6
of the report for that the
recommendations include a discretion for
the chair to increase the number of
speakers as well as an enshrined right
for certain speakers such as the local
Ward members the MP Parish Council and
the applicant to speak in addition to
any other speakers and there for your
consideration thank you chair thank you
are there any comments or
questions if not then we need someone H
councelor
Hancock um I'm not moving it chair I
wanted to move it first no I'm going I'm
going to take the questions right yeah
um it's it's actually more more of a
comment chair because the problem isn't
so much the number of speakers it's when
you get the repetition um and I think a
lot of this really comes down to the
chairing and perhaps we need to look at
the way that the uh planning team work
with people who are opposing to make
sure they present a more
united um more
united cohesive approach when they're
actually speaking at planning committee
um I mean one of the the ones which
brings immediate in mind we had one at
Kayla where we had 17 speakers literally
all saying the same thing that doesn't
help move the business forward and
that's what we need to try and stop we
don't really want to be stopping
speakers speaking if they've got
something relevant to say and I think an
arbitrary limit particularly as low as
what theyve put is difficult and I know
we've got the caveat in there that says
the chair can decide to have more but I
think that's the wrong approach I think
we need to look at how the meetings are
chaired and and actually just pulling up
people if they if they are repeating
what previous people have said so as it
stands I would reference it back to
standards thank you I'm going to ask Mrs
stug to respond to these collectively
and then when we move to the the
recommendations perhaps the Mover might
want to speak to it as well uh councelor
cupit thank you chair um yeah I I thank
standards committee for their working
looking into this matter but similar to
councel hanok has sort of reach a
separate conclusion on it um I just I
can't support the recommendations in the
paper or the the sort of conclusions
that the paper have reached I raised
similar concerns to what about to
outline at at standards committee but I
feel quite strongly on this issue
because I think it's quite important so
I want to highlight those again I don't
think there is a challenge of planning
committee sitting through the night 247
so I'm not sure why this guidance is
being pursued it feels like council is
trying to legislate for a problem that
doesn't really exist but which if if it
is pushed through today I think would
take our local planning system a step in
the wrong direction because it would act
as a deterrent and a complication to
local people having their say on
planning matters that can impact them as
I've said before planning applications
whether it's
submitting
application um when residents and
businesses have the the closest input
with the Council planning is
understandably quite complex and it can
be quite daunting particularly at
committee so we should be doing
everything we can to make it as seamless
and simple process as possible for
residents these revised rules today
massively over complicated that to me I
look at it and it's now six subsections
and it takes me a few minutes to work
out who might and might not be able to
speak if you're having to over describe
a rule to me and detail it in multiple
Parts you're over over legislating and
over complicating it and therefore
making it less accessible to Residents
in our communities on a similar Point as
per Point e uh in the recommendations
you're turning planning into a bit of a
fastest finger first style uh
registration whichever way the committee
decides applications can have a massive
impact on our communities and they're
usually contentious by the time they get
to committee so we shouldn't be reducing
it who gets to speak to who's quick
enough to register as the first three
speakers I also can't subscribe or feel
reassured by the final Clause that
allows the committee chair to allow
further speakers because to me that's
too late you've already deterred people
from having their say as they might
think it's unlikely that they would be
Exempted or allowed to register so we
want to but we should be making planning
system as transparent and open as
possible and I think that this goes in
the wrong direction with that so I just
can't support it today thanks thank you
councel C I'm going to go to counselor
Foster next because we seem to have some
technical blips going on here perhaps
it's trying to keep councelor Foster out
but I'm going to let him in so over to
you than
um I agree what's being said and I won't
repeat what's been said by the previous
uh two speakers but I agree
wholeheartedly with with those comments
I'll try and add something something
different I've been on uh the planning
committee for a number of years and when
you look at those longer applications
that take some time for those that have
been on there they can take sometimes
two sometimes three sometimes four hours
and longer and they are quite lengthy
and they can be an issue when they are
longer applications but they are very
very important applications and there's
an awful lot that goes on there uh what
I would say is if we're looking at
reducing the number of speakers a
speaker only gets to speak for three
minutes anyway it's going to affect the
overall time in the actual committee you
know to a very small amount so if you
for example uh added another uh figure
instead of five speakers you only making
a difference of six minutes it's six
minutes it makes to a uh to to a to a a
planning meeting no more than that and
if you think it's something so important
that it goes on for for let's say two
three hours the difference of six
minutes you know know that's what we're
looking at so i' ask councel I'd ask
everybody here to really consider not
having that figure in not having that uh
that limit in uh for those speakers I
think it's really important now I know
there's a there's part the there's
there's something that's been added
there for the discretion of the chair
that more should be allow be able to
speak but it shouldn't be down to the
discretion of one person it should be a
right of a resident to be able to
address the counselors at that planning
meeting they've got an actual right to
address all of us that are on there and
be heard and if they do start to repeat
themselves uh if they are having
difficulty that can be that's a sort of
thing that can be managed with the
discretion of the chair so I'd ask
Council to to yes there's some good
things in this but I'd ask Council
please don't limit it to three speakers
because there's lots of if you've ever
seen a planning or been there been to a
planning committee you'll find there's
lots of residents that have got to make
that need to make different points and
they've got a right to make it we're
talking about three minutes per person
they don't clog up it's not the speakers
that clog up if if anything it's the
councils that are asking questions over
and over and over for me that's how I
see it and the proof is is there if you
actually see the recordings of the
planning meeting so I'd ask uh for
Council to please not add that three
minute limit there's no need for it
thank you chair thank you Council
Dale
you I'll again not to repeat colleagues
but very much agree with what's been
said I'm not really clear what problem
we're trying to solve I think it's
pretty rare there's only a couple of
applications I can think of where we've
had a room full of speakers and and it
has taken all all afternoon to deal with
one application but you know those are
contentious issues and we deserve to
give a fair hearing to those communities
who who feel very strongly about them I
think planning committee is really
important because it's one of our
residents main interactions with the
council you know that and Leisure
centers and getting the bins emptied are
sort of the three main things that leure
that that residents will interact with
the council over so I think it's really
important that when they come to a an
event like that but most residents might
only ever attend one or less planning
committees meetings in their life so if
they are going to make the effort to
come I think they ought to feel like
they're not limited uh in the way that
this paper is seeking seeking to do and
I think it doesn't really tie in with
the openness and transparency and
collaboration uh sort of type message
that's coming from the administration I
think it would be better to just see
some better spacing of planning
applications if we have a lot of
contentious ones all at once have a
couple of planning meetings within a
month I appreciate that's more workload
for the councilors on the committee but
um that's better to me than restricting
the number of speakers it feels very
prescribed in terms of the approach so
in terms of Parish Council MP the
elected members speaking what happens if
most all of those people don't wish to
comment or speak at the Ping application
you've you've you've had slots
effectively there that are being used up
by specific people who may not want to
take those up so would we in those
circumstances allow additional residents
to speak I don't know it's it's not
really clear from the paper I think it's
there's also an unfairness as well
between the uh between the way that our
our system is warded so uh a single
member Ward could have an incredibly
contentious planning application but
only gets one slot to speak if you like
whereas a a fairly uncontentious
application in a three- member Ward may
get three members speaking which just
seems a bit skewiff and a bit unfair to
me and I think it puts a lot of pressure
on the chair as well to decide whether
an application is contentious enough to
wave this this limit to three speakers
or not and I don't necessarily think
that's unfair on the on the um on the
the chair couple of final points um I
have had some dialogue with Alan Mah
about the um about the start date for
this and would seek reassurance and
Clarity that this won't affect the
December meeting because I send letters
for the um the uh December meeting of
planning committee are going out today
so it feels a bit perverse to then
restrict um those members when they've
already found out that they should be
entitled to speak so we just ask for
clarity and and have it confirmed in the
minutes about that and I also would like
to propose an amendment chair but I'll
wait until it's moved in second that's
okay thank you well let Mr sterber
answer that bit about the December
meetings yes uh apologies um members I
should have said yes it would start from
January not from the December meeting
thank you Council Shipman you chair um I
I totally agree with everything that's
been said so far um the point I would
like to repeat though is that this
should be a job for the chair to be
dealing with this is not a job for the
Constitution to be trying to police
planning committee is one of the only
kind of places in this Council where the
residents themselves have a direct inut
into that decision making aspect so why
would we we be trying to limit limit
residents making representations on
something that is quite important in
most cases and something that each
resident will quite often have a
different point to make because it
affects their own property or their
community in it own way the it's
definitely the chair's responsibility to
be managing that um situation in the
planning committee and not for the
Constitution to be dealing with so I'll
be voting against it chair thank you
Council
jillet CH it feels like we're almost
having the the debate now before it's
actually proposed in second and uh so
I'll say some of my comments now
although they might be relevant later in
the proceedings as well as as a chair of
the standards committee uh this matter
came as the officer said to the May
meeting and there was some objections
there as uh as part of an overall
package of changes that came through and
so at that stage I was more than happy
to take it away and look look at it
again because I wasn't aware of the
rationale behind the decision and I've
never said on planning either and and so
I wasn't prepared to push through or
recommend a motion that I that I
couldn't put hand on heart and say I
agreed with and fully understand
understood and could defend um T taking
it away as a report details uh we are
actually an outlier when it comes to
what our rules are with with regards to
a planning uh committee and public
speaking we are one of the few
authorities that do actually allow
anybody who registers to turn up with a
guaranteed right to speak uh the report
itself does detail some of some of the
other naving authorities that have rules
um but if you look at virtually any
other uh District or Council and I've
looked at quite a few of all parties uh
including all the parties represented in
in this Council chamber or at least all
the groups should I say represented in
this Council chamber they they all have
a set of r and and the proposals here
are actually more generous than most
others um I too am a sad person because
I sat and watched the May meeting
because I wanted to refresh my moment as
to what was said at that meeting and
what the concerns were uh and a number
of the concerns were for example that if
counselor spoke or if the MP spoke or if
the if the town or Parish Council spoke
that would prevent or take up the time
and prevent resident speaking and I
thought that was a very fair and genuine
uh um argument which is why this
attempts to deal with that by giving
elected representatives the right to
speak and guaranteeing that but not
taking it away from the
public uh why should it be in the
Constitution because this is a statutary
committee uh that sits in a qu Jud
judicial capacity and in my experience
having worked with such bodies uh or
even with judicial bodies they need a
set of rules they need a set of rules to
guide them to be fair to everybody and
they need a set of rules that everybody
understands
uh the recommendation in there to have
that uh discretionary power for the
chair I actually think is important I
think it's really important because each
application is different what needs to
be said is different and if multiple
people come along with different
arguments from different groups as it
were in the community they should all be
heard I I agree with that but repetition
of the same point as I think has been
made previously doesn't make that point
any stronger and and the purpose of the
public speaking at these uh meetings
isn't to introduce new new measures or
to bring new factors to light it's
simply to assist the planning committee
to understand the report and previous
submissions so so I think is are some of
these numbers arbitrary yes but whatever
number you pick would be arbitrary and
there is an argument for or against I
think on balance this tries to be fair
it tries to be as inclusive as it
possibly can if it doesn't work I
wouldn't be a miss looking at it again
uh it's good to know from what people
have said that it won't affect many
applications so it may take some time to
bed down and see whether it would work
but I but I would commend it to
council Council
Barker I'll than
that can't beat that right thank you so
I'm I'm going to come back to Mr
Sternberg to uh answer quite a few of
those
points to be honest chair there weren't
many questions in that at all to answer
the only one was the one about when it
comes into effect approved and that as I
said will be
January thank you CH thank you so
Council J that was a proposal and
seconded by Council
Barker we we've already had a spoiler
alert that we're going to have an
amendment so Council
Dale thank you chair just bringing the
recommendations up I would uh like to
promote amendment that we delete
recommendations one and two and replace
with uh that Council notes the views of
standard committee uh but agrees to
maintain the current Arrangements
Without Limits on the number of speakers
uh and an additional uh recommendation
that the additional oh sorry rather the
guidance uh for speakers will be updated
to reiterate even further the point that
speakers should not repeat points
already made because I've looked at the
speaking guidance of speakers recently
uh and it does sort of make the point
but it could be clearer and I think that
would help to alleviate most of the
issues that we talked about today are
you in danger of negating that
recommendation
though Mr Sternberg
um yes I I think it does negate it
because you're saying don't do it which
would normally be done by a vote
against can I V make an amendment that
deletes uh 2 e
2 2
e okay uh sorry that uh
right we're going through each one
sentence by sentence so so it's not to e
we are not to e 3E should just say that
uh an unspecified uh number of other
speakers should be able to
register again I think that would negate
it I think rather than unspecified he
would have to change it to a number but
not leave it unspecified and that's what
we're checking Council Jill because I
think we're in the same
[Applause]
position
what about n
million has the same
effect sorry it's negated yeah I think
the view is that it's negated Council d
Mr
Sternberg thank you chair it's um on
page when I found it page 57 of the
agenda and it's the recommendations and
it's 3E that says that three other
speakers should be able to register to
speak either for or against that
application on a first come first served
basis
can we not shout out
please that's correct isn't it that's
the one you're seing to
change and that is the point of the
report is to uh give a limit to the
numbers who can speak so you're taking
away that limit by taking away
e I'm going to I've got some people
waiting that have waited and I'll come
back to you Council Dale if you want to
have think so Council Barry then Council
foret
yes chair um I'd like us to move on with
this uh because we're obviously not
getting very far with the the amendment
um and and my suggestion would be that
we move this and we we take the vote on
it with the the um the provisor that
there's a um a review done within 12
months that way if it's not worked it
can be referred back to standards
committee I'll let Council J think about
that well I I'll take the others on the
list we've got councelor foret and
councelor renick thanks chair I Echo um
councelor Barry's thoughts on this one
we seem to be retreading old ground on
this one in so much as we've sent
proposals through a scrutiny committee
and we're now expecting to do a whole
change to that in a full Council on the
Hop um I would move that we go forward
with this
recommendation as councilor bar has
outlined that this can be reviewed if it
isn't
practical Council
Shipman yeah chair just in terms of the
comments just I want to make an
amendment to say 200 instead of whatever
the limit is in the motion that doesn't
negate the motion that puts a limit of
people and and and on the points that
has just been said if the councilors on
the other side of the room want to go
back to their residents and tell them
that they're limiting the amount of
input that their residents can have at
planing committee by all means for your
boots but I don't think we should be
limiting residents coming to planning
committee to have their say it's not
just a case of all let's move on and see
what happens because you know like
anything in local government once
something's in place it very rarely gets
reviewed so let's not just rush into
something because it's easier and
everyone can get to PB quicker tonight I
think we need to think about this and
make sure it's the right decision not
something that's just rushed through so
I don't think we should be doing this I
think this the limit should be high
enough so that it doesn't prevent any of
our residents
being put off from planning committee or
having their UT so I would like to amend
it is put to 200 please have you got a
second you have a second so um so now we
have an amendment that is actually
through um of a number
now you laid the ground
work um to a number of 200 now for the
uh the number of speakers so um we're
now debating the amendment so who wishes
to speak on the
Amendment Karen Ren you you're on it
first so then we'll come to council
jillet very similar to coun shipment I
was going to ask if we could actually
take the three up to 20 with probably a
little bit more sensible amount just
that we've been to actually any has been
to to um um to particularly when you've
called in um planning application your
own area complex ones sometimes there is
more than one point to discuss and it's
very hard in the three minutes for three
people to get 20 points across so in a
practical way for those of us who have
attended um planning meetings I do think
this really constrains the big
applications I don't know why the
opposition are afraid of this I don't
know why we're trying to prevent people
from having their saying this open
transparent leadership we that were told
on the on your first council meeting
seems to been blown away so I think
perhaps councilor Shipman as usual is OV
exit and I think there's compromise in
between to actually um to do something
more like that's more sensible then
there is a definitely and and to the
amount of people who can because it's
very hard if you're going to say well it
depends what you're talking about well
how do you know until people have
actually gone in the room the three you
might have got might be saying the same
three things which means all the people
who haven't registered and this fingers
first thing is another really key point
you might get to read people whove got
poor representation and then the people
who might have made some really valid
points I really don't know um why why
why we're actually changing this I think
it's a really retrograde step I don't
want to be following other councils i'
will stand out of being a council that
listens to our residents and I'm I'm
proud that we've allowed this and I
don't see many planning there's only
very few that have gone on a bit you
know longer than what would like but I
think it's a really important key part
of our democracy that we're listen to
planning particularly because the labor
party spent a decade not delivering a
local plan which means we've had this
wild west of planning in our district
and therefore that's why people have had
to come and make representation because
we never had a Clarity on the local plan
and bear in mind you're playing around
particular with the local plan
again and we're not we're excluded from
those meetings I think now more than
ever we should have people actually been
able to actually look at what you're
trying to do and I I'm just a bit
suspicious you're trying to hide
something so I really feel strongly that
we should at least have
20 councilor gillet sort of drifting off
the point if you're just concentrating
on the amendment and I think the
difficulty councilor Dale has had in
actually coming up with something as an
alternative and then we' suddenly ended
up from 200 down to 20 or whatever it
shows how arbitrary these figures are um
I think everybody understands where we
are with this um I I see little point in
having any further debate I made my
point there are some other points I may
come back on in due course in the rest
of the debate but I I propose chair that
we move to the vote on this particular
Amendment first of all unfortunately
we've got some people still wanting to
speak on the amendment so we'll hear
those so
Council I'll second it as the next
speaker
chair thank you nice try I'm going I'm
going to hear one two more and then we
will go to the vote but I like what you
were doing Council CIT yeah just a quick
one chair in terms of adding on to this
amendment I I completely I can
understand the point of let's try it and
see but that has quite a massive counter
of let's not try it and see what happens
because the problem is if we introduce
the three speakers today let's say for a
year and then standard committee
realizes that it's not working for the
reasons that councelor renck just
outlined what happens to all those
contentious applications where where
people didn't get the chance to speak
are we going to revoke all those are we
going to go back to all those because
that's going to be quite a long planning
committee meeting if we're going to
review all those in a year's time so
again I fully support the amendment
that's been put down and and urge
Council today not to progress with this
alington
Stringer thank you chair uh this is a
fantastic example of people repeating
the same argument over and over again
extending the length of a meeting um
politicians back at it again are you
doing it
we are having a circular argument here
uh no matter what we increase the amount
to we can always have an extra person
speak um so rather than just bashing
each other here politically and
attacking each other on the color of
whatever party we might be which seems
to be what's happening so far I think
what we should do is really focus on the
resident and perhaps we should increase
that limit and allow more people to
speak fantastic but there should be a
review in place for sure with any number
that's set 200 is obviously too high if
you get a room full of 200 people you
are there therefore pushing other
planning applications out of the meeting
potentially so we have to be sensible
about this of course and I think we
should just get on with it let's
increase increase the limit by a small
amount but commit to a review I propose
that 20 20 20 is fine or second 20 um
but I would also put in there that we
have a review of that um in due course
within within a year and we get on with
it and stop just throwing accusations
around because that's exactly what we
shouldn't be doing we should be talking
about resid
coun Foster I am that's the last one I'm
allowing this I mean to cover what the
previous counselor said uh this this
isn't a political fight for me at all
this is a matter of residents being able
to speak and uh I'll repeat one more
thing one more thing and that's the
three minutes we're talking about three
minutes per resident it's it's
irrelevant to the length of length of a
meeting and that's if it's 200 or if
it's 20 we don't get 20 people speak on
even the the largest ones like we had in
killer Marsh no we're near 20 but we but
everybody had managed to have the say
and it's three minutes now there's one
more small small issue which could
happen if you limited limited it to
three and it was a contentious
application what could happen and this
could happen if developers know about
this you could get developers putting
three people up asking three people to
come and speak and that is the end of
opposition that residents so residents
wouldn't be able to come and speak on it
if they knew they had to get in first
now Consultants planning consultants and
residents are smart the first thing they
would do I believe is they put people up
first to speak in support of it and
that's your three that's your three
spaces took so it's a real issue for me
uh I I can I can see that happening a
mile off so I'd emplore counsel not to
uh not to go with limiting this to three
thank you chair yes go back to Second so
go back to councelor hanock then as the
second of the amendment thank you chair
um I mean I say this as someone who sits
on planning committee it's not that
unusual for us to have more than three
speakers quite often I think I mean I
think in the last one we may have had
four on that on a particular item so I
think three is far too low the key thing
and again I apologize for repeating is
making sure that we don't get the same
points Hamad own by that 20 people
because actually you do start to switch
off when you when you hear that and it
doesn't work in residents favor so the
the key thing here is how the meeting is
managed rather than put putting a number
or a cap on the number of speakers so
yeah I know we're taking the mick here
out of 200 speakers but that
realistically is going to cover
everything I can't remember the last
time we had 20 speakers it may have
happened but it's certainly a long time
ago because I've been on there for quite
a few years now um so so yeah to to me
putting a higher number it works we
should never fall foul of it and we need
to come down to actually instructing
people who speak and to uh and to
chairing it properly so I'm fully
supporting the amendment Council Shipman
is the proposer of the amendment yeah um
whenever you're trying to change
something or do something different we
should all be looking at what the
outcome is that we're trying to achieve
what because the only thing I can see
that would be achieved by this is the
limitation of speakers is there a
problem that officers have raised no is
there a problem that Council have raised
no so why would we be trying to limit
the speakers to three that yes 200 is a
wild number but that like counc L says
it's about putting a number in there
that doesn't restrict anybody in any
circumstance and didn't to be honest the
point that Council Foster made not even
coming to my mind but it's a perfectly
valid one in that planning Consultants
will start gaming the system and start
pushing residents even further away from
having that UT so I I would seriously
ask that the labor counselors on the
other side of the room support this
amendment and let's just leave things as
it is so that the residents can have
their say when they want to in planning
committee thank you chair thank you and
I think we just need some clarity on the
uh the point raised about people loading
it in one way or another in terms of the
actual document so Mr
Sternberg thank you chair um on page 61
of your report report Point c three
other people will be able to register to
speak for the application and three
other people will be able to speak an
objection to an application so there
would be three for and three against um
I just wanted to clarify that point
Thank You chair is it a point of
order what what a planning consultant
will arrange for is for that
someone to put an objection in and then
not show up to the
committee aren
they I right I think well the points
have been made and uh I think there's
been enough debate about the amendment
so we are going to move to a vote on the
amendment and the amendment is about um
increasing the number of speakers to
200 so um this is whether you're in
favor of the amendment against or
abstain so over your voting
pants
that's it okay so can we have the final
decision then
please so the amendment is
lost so we're going back to the
substantive
debate
so there's a second OT Amendment now is
there so
um right so counselor renck over to you
for your
proposal so as a pragmatic to 20 I don't
think that will change very much in
terms of the operations of the planning
committee I think it's a sensible
pragmatic it does allow I think the
right amount of people to speak as far
as I'm aware from people Council hano's
already said in his long time being on
the planning committee has not seen more
than TW than 20 but it does allow that
nine or 10 or 11 people to come that
might come on a very contentious um
planning application and I think we
should be brave and make time for
that coun Addington
Stringer I'm I'm not going to repeat
myself again but just comes back to go
chairmanship and making sure that
developers don't load 20 people into the
room that's a seconding we're now
debating the next Amendment this time on
the number 20
any comments or anybody wanting to add
to the
debate Council Barker Baker
sorry well close somebody's been
[Laughter]
insulted yeah
well i' speak in support of this second
Amendment that's a more pragmatic number
and I agree with the reasons for it
I'd just like to clarify which
recommendation it is is it not to e of
the
report thank
you that's
correct Council
Barry yeah um in as much as how many
people come to these planning committees
I can recall as over to two days because
of the amount of people that came to
talk on it and that went on for a long
long time people have got the right to
write in and put their objections
forward they can also go to their Parish
counsels their District counselors and
ask them to put their reasons forward
there is
enough um stuff in here that will allow
people to have their voice I I cannot
vote for this amendment I'm afraid
because it's not taking us anywhere um
we need to get these amendments out of
the way get back to the main
um Mo business and then get it put
forward and then like we've said before
get a review if everybody saw adamant
that there's going to be a failure to
this then that's fine let's put a review
into it we'll know then whether we're
going forward or not um and you know as
for the comment that Council Shipman
made about things not ever getting
reviewed well I'd love to know which
Council you work for because we review
them all the time thank you very much
sir thank
you other comments then I'm going to go
back to councelor renick as the
proposer great I think it's a pragmatic
approach and Council might have been to
at over but that was what won in in the
whole you know last 20 years I think
just just for the sake of that one other
ashover that might come through let
allowing people to have their say I
think this is a sensible compromise
solution and I I would expect anybody
who values their residents ability to
come and actually talk about their
planning applications in their area
should not be voting against
this so we now move to the next
Amendment vote which is about the number
20 so uh time to
vote
okay so we'll have the
results one vote in it the amendment is
lost so we come to the uh substantive
uh
motion you Council Dale you trying
another number
out 21 yeah um 18 no I've resigned
myself to the fact that uh that the
existing motion is going to be voted on
I just wanted to clarify well two points
really the uh the first is to clarify
what Mrs Sternberg said a moment ago
about the wording of uh recommendation
2E um I I don't think the wording is
clear enough in this recommendation
because I read that to say three other
speakers should be able to register to
speak either for or against an
application I read that to be a total of
three of which they can either be for or
against if it should be the way that Mrs
St suggested I think it should say three
of the uh three of the speakers should
be able to speak either four and three
should be able to speak against or the
repetition of the word three just to
make that absolutely clear um if we're
if we're happy to agree to that and then
the other thing I'd like do is request a
recorded
vote so we need to clarify
the
but we CC
clarifying
that yes we're just going to get Mr stur
to clarify the answer and response to
council
Dale thank you yeah I take the point and
if members are happy to add in all three
against an application to make it three
for or three against to clarify that
that is the intent of the report as I
read out on page 61 so thank you to
council gillet as the move of the motion
and the chair of the standard committee
that discussed it I interpret it in the
way that Mr Sternberg said um and and
therefore um I don't think it's needed
but if that amendment is is moved I have
no objections and I would be more than
happy to accept it I think if we had a
policy that prevented one party whether
it's an objector or supporter from
speaking I don't think that would stand
legal challenge anyway uh and I would
expect the chair to interpret in the way
we've discussed it but if it helps I'm
more than happy just to accept that
minor Amendment just just to make it
perfectly clear in any circumstance are
you accepting that Council Dale yeah
thank you and thank you to council
jillet so um the uh friendly Amendment
um being added to that for
clarification is accepted thank you so
are you still wanting the recorded vote
on that Amendment now no or the whole
thing the right anything else on the
substantive councilor
you you do yes that's why I'm saying is
there anything else anybody else wants
to say in terms of the
substantive
motion if not Council Jill it to
reply one or two of the points that were
mentioned first of all I just want to
reject councelor Shipman's comment that
this is about getting through a meeting
quicker so that people can go to the pub
I think that's quite insulting to the
members of the planning committee uh I I
have every confidence that whatever the
rules are they will do their best and
they will listen to the arguments and
the uh recommendations put forward to
them and then make up a decision based
on what they think is the appropriate
decision as far as the review is
concerned well this Council conducts a
review every year of its Constitution
we're in the middle of one right now uh
and members of the majority group uh
opposition group sit on it so there
there will be nothing wrong in actually
in anybody in this Council chamber who
wants part of the Constitution reviewing
to let either myself know or let Mrs
Sternberg know and in fact as a plug if
there's anything anything you can think
of now that we should be looking at now
is the time to tell us as well so that
we can take that as as part of the
review um as I said every Council not
every Council the vast majority of
councils of whatever political
persuasion have rules and this is a set
of rules and we do it for other things
as well on the agenda for this meeting
is public participation there are limits
as to how many people can come along and
speak there and I'm sure um looking at
many of people in this room are on
Parish councils you will have a similar
rule you exactly the same thing to
govern how that meeting runs how many
people can speak and how long they are
given to
speak and therefore this is no different
from that but this as I say this is a
statutory committee it's in a quazi
dudal capacity it needs certain rules to
guide it ours are not out of the
ordinary in fact they are more generous
than than um most other councils and and
therefore I would continue to recommend
it to council and hope everybody would
support it thank you Council gillet so
um we are going to move to a recorded
vote what that means in terms of our new
technology is that this time when we
vote on our pads and you'll see all the
names come up there those will then be
taken and then added to the record of
minutes so recorded votes are actually
each of your names with the way you
voted will be in the
minutes so um hope that's clear yeah you
go move to your voting pads then
please
okay so see the results then
please so that is carried and as I say
those uh that record of voting will
appear in the
minutes item 10 then appointment of
members to represent the council and
outside bodies so again to Mrs Sternberg
over two please thank you
chair thank you chair the number of
outside bodies to which the council
appoints n uh nominations nominees has
been reviewed organizations were
contacted individually to establish if
they still want a council nominee as a
result the organizations listed in
paragraph 1.3 indicated they would like
such a council representative and the
recommendation is that the appointments
proposed in paragraph 1.3 are made and
stand till May 2024 thank you chair any
comments or questions about
that so then we need to move the
recommend commendations Council Barker
yeah can I move those recommendations
that are in 1.3 please a
second thank you Council
Barry right we move unless there's any
comments or questions following moving
of the
recommendations and we move to the vote
please
and you could see the
results thank you that's carried so item
11 then to answer any questions from
Members under procedure rule
9.2 so we have a number of uh questions
submitted so we'll start with question a
council
gillet
of the Winder Road area of Clay Cross
suffered cat catastrophic flooding of
their homes as a result of storm BS many
now face the prospect of being unable to
live in their homes for several months
along with huge financial costs and
emotional trauma can the leader of the
council tell members what action this
Authority took to help residents to deal
with the crisis Council bker to reply
thank you chair yeah it was was
catastrophic as you say and now we
deeply saddened by the loss of life
Devastation for property and hardship
caused to many in our district and
darish as a
whole while I whil I understand why you
were raising the wind Road incident
other areas in our district were're also
severely impacted and colleagues in
eckington renish show have also been
raising similar concerns I'm sure you'll
have read that the rain four we got was
unprecedented the Met Office recorded
the three 3day period is the wetest on
record for the region and the 20th of
October Sheffer recorded their single
wetest October day since records began
some 140 year ago 185 owns were flooded
in our district along with 10 businesses
Clay Cross Sher and wingerworth
eckington and renishaw were all badly
affected our Depot at eckington was also
flooded up to half a meter in places
damaging the building and Welfare
facilities and a lot of the equipment I
went down just after and I saw
photographs that I know all the Senior
Management and all the staff at the
Depot had spent all weekend trying to
clear it out and I don't think I think
the bin lares went out on the Monday
which were incredible to say it say it
with this eye it all the all the
building were flooded uh it were it were
terrible and and thanks again to all the
staff involved for for trying to sort
that uh we were part of the emergency
planning process and again thanks to to
our team
uh brought together all the partners
including the environment agency the
flood Authority met office and Emergency
Services who over the weekend battled
with the serer water that were traveling
through darbishire we got it first where
it carried on going as Derby were
impacted on the Saturday uh with major
incidents being called right right
through area washing Nottingham sh
officers of the across the county worked
tirelessly together over the weekend
water teams were stood up by the fire
service environment agency field teams
were clearly clearing grids and the
County Council made available pumps and
tankers and got flood signage out we
along with our colleagues at other
districts supported the residents who
contacted us with practical help filling
and distributing sandbags sign posing to
the agencies who could offer help we
also need to clean and repair the depot
as I've said and we got everything
sorted for Monday on Monday senior
officers visit all the areas worst
impacted and the contact center made
over 100 welfare CS to Residents we
stood up staff and vehicles to support
the darish wide recovery effort and
provide a free refu service to Residents
who needed to clear their homes our
Engineers carried out inspections of the
worst affected areas to identify any
immediate remedial work that were needed
on Friday following the floods the
government agreed grant funding to
support those affect
and by the following Tuesday residents
were access accessing the grants to date
I think we've issued 44,000 in Grants uh
and we've offered council tax relief to
about just over a 100 households uh so
we've done what we can uh that's what we
did uh during the storm and just after
have supplementary question Council
jillet for that that to outline um I I I
I want to start off actually by
recognizing the hard work of the staff
um I've been down there several times
and um after the initial weekend I think
our staff here played a tremendous part
in supporting those residents and I know
a number of them spoke to me personally
and said how appreciative they were of
the hard work that was put in and I also
actually want to just name the managing
director because I know he went down on
the Monday and he took a lot of the
anger of the residents and I must admit
I went down a few hours later and I took
some that anger as well but you made my
life a little bit easier but but I think
it shows leadership that you actually
went down there I think that ought to be
recognized um the uh residents are
obviously angry with this Authority uh
and there may be legal proceedings but I
don't want to raise that as my
supplementary question my supplementary
question is about the future um because
the big concern is what is going to take
place to make sure this never happens
again that is the responsibility
predominantly of the County Council in
its capacity as lead local flood
Authority but it's clear from the county
council's documentation strategy that
there is roles for other agencies
including this Authority so so my
question for the leader is will you
ensure that this Authority plays a major
role in the investigation that will take
place or is taking place and that it
will Champion the cause of the local
residents there to make sure that all
measures are put in place that can be
Reily put in place to make sure that
they are never the victim of flooding
again Council
B yes is the answer to that Kevin
shortly but I think we we're we're also
reviewing all the emergency planning uh
incident response AR we Le that that uh
we feel went well but there's always
lessons to be learned from the them
events we're working with the flood
Authority through a darbishire wide
Recovery Group on prevention and
lobbying for technical reviews for all
the sites affected uh because what we we
if we can we don't want it to happen
again we are working with Partners
across darish and defra to launch a
flood prevention scheme uh and as assist
Property Owners to improve their own
flood
resilience uh on Thursday the 16th
senior officers attended a public
meeting with residence of Winder Road
and as a result the manag director has
written to em Alexander I think and
Chris wning at darisha to ask that
consideration be given to North tarisha
prevention group being created with all
relevant agencies to involved to work to
ensure and and to prevent it don't
happen again and and yes I think you're
right Kevin we do need to involve local
members and Parish councils in any of
them discussions with the local
knowledge and all that sort of stuff so
it's a big ask but uh if we can uh help
stop it again then uh we'll do all we
can Le thank you question B then Council
Foster's question to council
Barker yeah uh we're back to the local
plan again and we've already spoken
about this when it came to the uh the
minutes today I'm increasing ly
concerned I was at the last meeting and
I'm increasingly concerned now because
this is getting slippier than ever and
we can't actually find out what is going
on and I'm hoping we do get some clarity
at this point what I don't want could
you move to your question please well
what I don't want what I'm saying is I
don't want is a not across the room uh
on camera at this time I'd like an
answer on this so the question is I'll
read it out following the leader's
commitment at the last full council
meeting can he confirm when and how will
the minutes or notes of the council's
working group meeting on the local plan
be made available to all members and the
public thank you par could to
reply yeah thank you for uh question
councilor Foster Mark if we could call
you that uh I suspect you already know
what I'm going to say my guess is that
you've probably read the letter that
I've sent back to dronfield Town Council
that that I wrote last week so uh but
anyway for the benefit at rest at
Council I will reiterate what I've said
in that letter and the fact that the
agreed terms are reference to the
working group are that the local plan
review working group is an informal
group whose purpose is to advise
officers of members in reaching any
decisions to moving planning policy
forward I'm informed that the working
group doesn't legally have to have notes
it does not have to be open to public
either and the know them know the notes
but we have agreed that the notes would
be taken at each meeting of the working
group the notes from the working group
meetings will be attached to quarterly
reports presented to scrutiny committees
and cabinet with an annual report to
present it at full Council these reports
to the Committees will be published in
advance of the relevant meetings and as
such will be in the public domain I hope
that answers your concerns I hope that's
clear supplementary question Council
Foster answer counselor um supplementary
um I'd be happy to hear this here but
I'd also like this one in writing if
that is possible if we can ask for that
uh so aside from the fact that you've
already included chairs and vice chairs
on the local plan working group and that
this year two Vice chairs happen to be
from our political group this is the
only group or committee that political
groups are not allowed to choose their
own
Representatives as something as
contentious and important to local
residents as the local plan this should
not be the case we should be able to
choose our R and I still believe that
and I said it before so my question
specifically and for the record if it
can be recorded like this it's a very
very clear one will you let political
groups choose their own representatives
and I'd like that not just here on
camera but I'd like that in writing if
that's okay thank you chair
Council
Sor yeah as again stated in the letter
that I keep waving
about the working group is not a
committee and as such there is no legal
requirement for it to be politically
proportionate as a working party it is
not a decision making body as I have
said it is it is there to advise I would
also like to point out that th whilst
you were in control the Steering group
only met twice in four years and the
notes from those meetings were never
published or in the public domain so I'm
just saying so that's clear for you it's
staying as it is and I can put that in
writing if you want in fact I've already
written it
down can now that you've that's it
you've had your supplement you've had
your supplementary and um question C
Council cupit your questions Council
baret yeah would the leader of the
council outline his administration's
views regarding untidy and unfin
unfinished plots of land in the
district
I'm
today there's other people in
real now thanks for this it would have
been Andy really to know which bit bit
of land you about to be honest you but I
assume it's probably about them bits of
Landing mle uh near the shop I might be
wrong uh but again it's a similar
question you'll probably know what I'm
going to say given you've been trying to
resolve it for last four years probably
uh and having said that we were trying
for probably longer than that when we
were in control if it's that then bits
of land if it's not then I'll got
another answer more generally
which is we're reviewing all the plots
of land as part of our new asset
management and housing strategy there is
already a process in place for selling
plots our review intends to make sure
that we take a strategic approach to
selling plots rather than just selling
them on a caseby Case basis we are not
responsible for maintaining privately
owned plots if there are problems with
privately owned plots such as unfinished
structures or untidy conditions we would
need to consider enforcement action
where appropriate we can take action
against untiy plots of land particularly
if they attract rodents or flighty if it
is the mle one for the benefit of
council I I can State what you probably
already know that the land at Priestly
have know we are trying to strategically
purchase but it's very slow we continue
to negotiate with the land owner we've
also written to him asking him to
address the flight if in an overgrown
vegetation he hasn't responded so we're
now looking at enforcement
options our with close has just has two
unfinished plots but the crown owns them
and it's and it is time consuming and a
legal process to resolve it so I hope
that helps that's a cupit supplementary
question thanks councilor Barker um that
is helpful and I thank officers for
their work in that regard but that they
weren't actually the plots of land I was
sort of thinking of in in asking the the
more general question question uh
specifically I feel like the council
isn't sending the right message in this
regard as the council's left a green
homes gramp fund demolition site in
mickley which should be being turned
into much needed parking to overgrow and
become a litter trap whilst this is no
criticism of officers can I ask you to
commit to completing this as soon as
possible and getting me a time frame for
the completion within the next week or
so say because that is obviously sending
the wrong message to The Wider district
and specifically to the other plots in
counc
Mar yes I can't do that now I didn't
know about that so I will look into that
and we'll get you a written
response as soon as we can thank you
question D then Council Dale then to
council
Barker sorry it fell within your
portfolio Nigel um will the leader of
the council please confirm the
administration's current intentions with
regard to the PA's parking strategy and
what is to happen with the H budget
allocation of 280,000 perom to support
parking improvements in the states where
the council is the principal and primary
owner of properties thank you Council
parket to respond yeah thanks again and
thanks for your question Alex although I
do find it somewhat ironic that you
choose to ask this one I think you could
have asked one of other three it might
have been more appropriate given that
the last Administration spent nearly
£160,000 of tenants rental income mostly
nap andol I'll keep reminding you about
that Alex and nice VI down the Dale I
said or aale that was me joke at the
time I'll keep on with thank
you you weren't here to hear it you you
were badly no it co when you got Co but
basically and and to pay for that for
them improvements you would benefited 42
tenants in three Wards and we all know
where the other Wards were and that
works out at
£3,800 per tenant and many of them
tenants don't own a car
so with that in mind we've decided to
review the program however the money is
still in the
budget uh and I know there's a motion on
this later in in the on the agenda uh
and I will try to address some of those
issues because it will be a debate then
not
just answer a secondary question if
that's all right with you I can ask a
second obvious it can that's right sorry
sorry another question councel Dale
yeah I mean as it happens The Works in
appol are still not finished actually so
I would ask what uh what kler Barker
says to those residents in apol but not
just appol those residents in uh in
wingerworth in kiler Marsh in eckington
in Kut Thorp and various other areas
where we were pursuing schemes where we
had consulted in many of the cases uh
and where you know the the residents
quite rightly were expecting that we
would we would um have some sort of
intervention and and now um there is
uncertainty was that a
question right I say sorry Council bar
the beginning I think I those in
response to the motion uh and I I've
said the money is still there and and
those those places are still being
reviewed and looked at nothing's been
took out yet so uh but we are looking at
it which I'll explain in Greater detail
in response to the motion thank you so
item 12 then to consider motions from
Members under procedure rule number 10
first motion is moved by councilor
adlington Stringer over to
you thank you
chair the following motion was
previously seconded and now
isn't I'm hoping that today one of 54
councilors might want to join me in
calling on our government to bring an
end to horrific violence that we have
seen
to
suffering and to call for a
ceasefire I have spoken with various
members of the council in leadership
positions in opposition parties and so
far nobody seems to be prepared to do
that that saddens me that shocks
me and the silence that I hear right now
and the silence that I might have to sit
and here when we don't have a debate we
don't have a vote says more more than
any of you are prepared
to we have seen hideous actions by Hamas
on the o on October
7th and we have seen a disproportionate
response from Israel ever since but what
disappoints me more than any of that is
a response by British politicians of all
levels I'm hoping that we can come
together as a council to represent our
residents as I've outlined in this
motion to call out all for forms of
discrimination which I've seen and
witnessed in our district from all sides
we should come together combat that and
call for
peace now to me that seems very
straightforward seems an easy thing to
do but for many of you it
isn't and I've struggled to understand
why that is when I submitted this motion
I received a call from the monitoring
officer she told me the word ceasefire
had become politically charged
we heard from the chair of this council
at the start of the
meeting we talked about membrance day we
fly Ukrainian flag outside this
building yet
nobody is prepared to talk about
this why is that well I've heard from
the leadership of this Council that it's
marching orders from upstairs and I feel
the same is true for the opposition as
well here people are putting the
interest of their party
ahead of
people on all sides of a brutal brutal
War it's my
turn you all have an opportunity now
there's a motion ahead of
you to give us an opportunity to at
least
debate to have an opportunity to
vote I expect I know what will happen
next it's what's been happening over the
last couple of
weeks
more
silence this is your opportunity it's in
the minutes it'll be here for us to look
back up again the same way the Iraq
War this is your moment I'll leave it
with you just know whatever you
do Generations will look back at this
thank you
chair thank you do we have a second
uh
second no seconder therefore the motion
Falls to Move Motion B moved by Council
cupit to you Council
cupit thank you chair um I was going to
bring this discussion forward at what
used to be the local plan Steering group
but as that no longer exists I've
brought it here today um separate to the
the overarching local plan there's
obviously an ability for councils to
pursue detailed planning policies and
stances through supplementary
supplementary planning documents the
purpose of these is to help applicants
communities and Committee in decision
making but also to provide an additional
steer and Detail in relation to specific
local needs in an area or District to
give a couple of examples of why these
are needed I think and to expand on a
couple of those referenced in the motion
that I put forward today as many many
members know we're fa facing an
increasing number of expansive
applications for solar farms in our area
whilst I think we're all supportive of
renewable and clean energy these
applications such as the recently
refused oakor and sherland one and one
that's likely upcoming in Morton and the
surrounding area are presenting a
dilemma and a judgment call in terms of
the impact on our landscape and the vast
nature of them in contrast to the clean
energy so whilst I'm not seeking to
express a view or Judgment of those
upcoming ones or current ones I think it
is an issue we should seek to look at in
the round on a principal basis and
decide our principles on them similarly
there's the opportunity to be stronger
on some issues to better reflect the
demand and character of our specific
District that covers the other other
references in bullet points in terms of
going one step ahead on what we want
from any new developments in terms of
Wildlife and energy measures as well as
looking at for our town centers ensuring
a variety of attractions by this I mean
ensuring we don't have all the same type
of business in a town center and that is
in our power be that and not criticizing
any any business or type of business all
takeaways all services or even all
Bakers or things like that finally I
know we have different views on this but
recent meetings and events such as on
the Clay Cross Town deal highlight the
council's planning policy on car parking
isn't clear enough and probably doesn't
reflect current demands or needs that
doesn't just apply to town centers and I
don't just even reference Clay Cross as
I know colleagues in eckington drum
field and killer Marsh have had similar
issues with individual applications in
their Town centers but it also applies
to new development where I get lots of
feedback there isn't enough parking or
visitor parking I know this is something
that the County Council is working on on
a countywide basis but I think it would
be good to reflect the specific Rural
and District position we have here so I
hope all members will recognize there's
some important topics to discuss and
debate and feed into and so I hope uh
members today will support the
establishment of this
group do do we have a second Council
Dale yeah happy to second and would like
to reserve my right to speak thank you
chair fine thank you Council
Barker yeah thank you chair yeah I get
I'm getting the
message well I'm sure you're aware that
that uh red based on recent government
announcements there's likely to be
changes to the local plan making process
over the next 12 months the new system
will introduce supplementary plans which
will replace the supplementary planning
documents spds and as a result any work
currently being done on these spds is
going to be largely be wasted however
the research and data collection around
issues such as renewable energy climate
change biodiversity Town Center planning
car parking strategy I imagine that went
on your list I've just added it uh will
continue ensuring they based on solid
evidence the local plan working group we
were responsible for considering any
future supplementary plans uh and
therefore we'll be supporting we won't
be supporting this motion I'm sure
Council liot who's on the steering group
uh working party should I say uh will be
able to uh feed in some of those
concerns thank
you any other comments or
questions come back to council Dale
thanks chair um I find it interesting
that uh what councelor Barker said in
relation to the W Local plan working
group and again the sadow that I am
watching back the uh the last meeting um
I know that councel Barker said at the
time we need to get on with this
referring to the local plan review the
sooner we make a start on it the better
uh cancel Pickering himself said that
it's long overdue we want to Kickstart
this and get on with it uh and then
cancel pick went Pickering went on to
criticize the last Administration for
doing nothing for the last 18 months and
then we had all the palava of that
meeting to set up the local plan working
group and then it's had its first
meeting and it's promptly decided to do
nothing which was Labor's mantra for the
whole of the past 14 years it was in in
administration uh when it allowed the
last local plan to expire and didn't
make a start and didn't uh successfully
complete the creation of the last local
plan it left it to us to do in our
Administration I just find that pretty
astonishing that we have here an
opportunity to influence broader
planning policy planning policy is
always not just about local plans
they're always intended to be an
overarching document and to have more
detail underneath this is a great
opportunity to do that to write the
wrongs of the last meeting in terms of
local plan working group and actually to
get on and make some changes but we're
sat back waiting for government policy
to change and we did that for all of the
past 11 12 years whatever it was of the
last Administration and we ended up with
um you know uncontrolled speculative
Development Across the South and it was
I'll be honest it was predominantly
labor Wars that were adversely affected
by it and I just can't understand how
you can't see that that is the wrong
approach this is a great opportunity to
to Really enhance planning policy and I
would encourage all members to to vote
for this this
motion Council cupit as the
Mover just to to wrap up yeah I think i'
appreciate Council dark's response but
disappointing because as we know the the
local plan Steering group that's been
set up and informal working group is
informal doesn't report back and it
disenfranchises the majority of members
in this chamber whereas these are quite
specific and detailed um you know
policies that we were putting forward
and no respect to any Representatives on
on that Steering group but there's
different members who may want to feed
in on different things from town centers
from you know that represent areas with
solar Farms Etc so I would again urge
all members to to think carefully in in
supporting this um and again can I call
for a recorded vote uh just when we go
to this thanks need a
third thank you so that's a recorded
vote so we are going to move to a vote
on this motion which is recorded So once
again uh same procedures before voting
but it will form part of the minute so
if we go to voting
please
one of two just nipped out the room so
if we could go to the final vote then
please that's it the motion is
lost thank you so motion C moved by
councilor Dale over to
you uh thank you chair um obviously
follows the question we had earlier and
I welcome uh Council Barker's
announcement that the budget is not uh
not lost if you like um and and fully
accept that it's absolutely your
prerogative as a new Administration to
review uh any policy any strategy
anything that the last Administration
was doing and you know wholly accept
that um I think from my perspective what
I'm really asking here is that we don't
lose sight to the fact that a parking is
a significant issue for a lot of our
residents and B that we have powers we
have the ab ability uh to do things
about that particularly where we are the
principal and primary landowner and you
know we have a lot of counil own
properties and and I would argue that
also that tends to be where most of our
acute parking problems are you know poor
design from many years ago that didn't
factor in the fact that uh families have
a lot more Vehicles now than they used
to uh and so yeah I would say that there
is an opportunity there and actually my
view of local government is that you
know we have a duty to support our
residents and to make life better in any
way that we can can and therefore I'd
like to see um some support for this
motion I'd like as as I say for the
commitment to that that budget
allocation to remain in place
specifically for dealing with parking
issues the other aspect to this is
during the uh during the past few months
actually probably just prior to the
election I was contacted by a few
residents who highlighted the need for
some form of loan scheme so that they
could enable uh themselves to be able to
put a driveway on the property uh and I
think it struck me as a really good idea
and if obvious if the administration is
not keen on the previous parking
strategy I think it's another way in
which we can actually have an impact on
dealing with parking issues by opening
up the opportunity to people who might
not otherwise be able to afford it to
put in place their own driveway we can
um we can agree a spec and a design for
that and obviously you know in terms of
keeping our Estates clean and tidy and
looking looking good and everything and
also in terms of surface water run off
all the you know permeability of the
surface and those sort of things from a
from a planning perspective uh to make
it simple um so yeah that's the
justification for the report I want to
want to ensure that we continue to spend
that money on parking improvements and
do what we can as an organization I
appreciate we're not the only Authority
uh responsible uh and also whether that
that uh that idea around a tenant loan
scheme uh could be looked at and
obviously if a report can be brought
back to full Council so that we can
explore and all members be able to uh
feed into the next steps thank you chair
thank you you have a second there
Council cupit are you reserving your
right thank you so any comments on this
councilor adlington
Stringer
Council we'll go with you sure Council B
I'll go with you because I said it thank
you ch um to me this is a a
demonstration of the lack of joined up
thinking here we've just had a motion
about climate change mitigation measures
and now we're talking about car parking
I'm not sure how you can bring both
those motions together uh it seems very
strange um um you said many families own
more cars than they ever have yes that's
because of years of successive failures
to implement decent public transport
infrastructure in our area I live in a
ward where I cannot have a car I would
love to not have a car it's impossible
to get around this District without a
car uh just yesterday actually I was in
wingerworth on the local park I had two
or three people different times come up
to me and say I've been still waiting
for a bus and N N's turned up that is
the tale of where we live it's time and
time again it's
it's classic so we are forcing people
into car ownership that's the first
problem the second problem now or or
your supposed solution to this problem
which successive councils and
governments have created is to make
residents choose between having a garden
a green
space or a driveway that's the solution
to concrete over a place for their
children to play for something which we
should be promoting a wild space
somewhere for a fox or a hedgehog to be
somewhere for them to enjoy not more
tarmac the answer to this is investing
in public transport supporting people
with active travel it's not through more
concrete and getting people more cars
and putting more concrete and more cars
what happens with the next government
the next Council we just build another
level on people's driveways and keep
going up and up and up it's ridiculous
and it's it's a failure to join up the
thinking and I certainly won't be
supporting this and I'd urge everyone
else to do the same thank you very much
thank you Council
yeah thanks for that Frank yeah and yeah
uh we take on board what you say Frank
but we where we are and I'm answering
the question that's in front of me uh it
is in an Ideal World I think you we
could do all that but in the answer to
councilor Dale's question on the issue
hopefully I made it clear that the car
parking program is still under review we
are open to considering uh the motion
but I need need to make clear that the
council to the council the proposal to
loan HRA money to tenants isn't
straightforward indeed quite the reverse
it is complex and will have its
challenges and that might explain why
the conservative group only want to
introduce such a policy now when they're
in opposition there's also an issue of
fairness for tenants since a number of
tenants have already benefited from the
existing scheme we're nowhere there to
provide additional parking provision
without having to borrow money to pay
for it this proposal require future
beneficiaries of a revage scheme to have
to take on debt and I would understand
it if some of them felt AG grieved by
having to do that also as alluded to in
my previous answer was the challenges
that a mix tenure of many Estates would
cause when drafting a policy that uses
only HRA funding to pay for extra
parking places this proposal does
nothing directly to help those who own
their own homes or the property from
someone other than the council yet they
would benefit indirectly from additional
off street parking because it would free
more on Street places but the policy
just asked HRA tenants to foot the bill
we believe that the fairer solution for
all HRA payers and non HRA payers in
areas of mixed tenure would be to have
projects jointly funded by both this
Council and the County council with that
mind I would like to move an amendment
which doesn't change the sentiment of
the original motion but includes a
request that the County Council as the
highways Authority match fund our
allocation if the amendment is passed
cabinet will take the proposal away and
once we're in receipt of a response from
the County Council give the proposal
proper consideration and will then
report back to this Council in due
course thank you uh have we got the
amendment
somewhere me that's the amendment with
the track changer Martin you said it
were in big letters apparently there are
paper copies around and
about they not big like
m
well that technology is not
work it's a good job we go and print it
off
then got what you call theat
glasses
to speak don't
belong yeah why some green some
red
do you want five minutes to read it Alex
while we all got to
toilet I've done it see original there's
no
changes well before you even move
Council we don't even have a second
sorry they second the amendment
somebody so so you're seconding
councelor Burkin are you reserving your
right to
reply yeah right so we do have a
second yes Council Birkin is going to
Second it um I think we're now just
having a a short break while uh some
people just assimilate the additional
wording
right everyone so we've had time now to
uh look at the proposed amendment that
has been put forward by Council Barker
and seconded by Council Burkin so we're
now debating the
amendment so Council Shipman your light
had come up before the amendment are you
wanting to just speak on the amendment
now I
was I I agree I don't if it's I I agree
with the um the sentiments of of most of
what's been proposed as the amendment
apart from the loan aspect I didn't I
don't agree with with it in the original
motion and I don't agree with it
remaining in the amended motion we're
not Lloyd's Bank we're Northeast AR
District Council and whilst it it might
be well meaning that people need
somewhere to go to take a loan we're
basically putting people in debt as a
council that's not the statutary duty of
this Council and it's not one we should
even be engaging in I'm sure um Council
Dale has put forward the motion might
propose us at County who um might have
some in the reserve just about left to
um fund this sort of scheme but
Northeast AR District Council should not
be loaning people money so they can put
driveways in um so I would hopefully if
councelor um Barker will accept to
remove for for for the amendment to
actually include the removal of that
loan aspect the rest I completely agree
with and I will be supporting it but I'd
like to see that bit removed if
possible counc bar you want him to
accept that friendly Amendment or
otherwise speak and speak again on that
line on that line uh whe you're
accepting it or not
uh no because I think that might negate
the whole motion that's what I'm a bit
worried
about well that suggested Amendment
isn't accepted so we we're sticking to
Amendment as proposed Council
Dale thank you chair getting quite
confusing this one um just responding to
councelor Barker's comments in terms
terms of the complexity of having a loan
scheme I appreciate it is you know it
perhaps is complex in answer to the
point about whether uh whether it was
thought of before and not dealt with I
genuinely can say it was thought of
during the election campaign and I had a
resident i' had quite a few residents
actually who came to me saying we would
be willing to to take out a loan for
this Improvement so I think I think ker
Shipman's in danger of putting ideolog
ideology in in you know in face of sort
of practicalities and what some of our
residents actually want I think that
point around fairness for tenants as
well the difference between there is a
difference between allowing them to
install a parking space on their
driveway uh and uh if ker adlington
Stringer will allow us while we're also
trying to protect the foxes apparently
um but that difference between
installing a parking space on your
driveway as opposed to off the highway
on a piece of common land that that's
very clearly shared parking space so I
don't necessarily agree that there is a
a fairness issue here for tenants
because this is a distinct improve
Improvement uh to you know on just
having parking nearby rather than
actually on your own driveway I think
the trouble with the amendment to the
motion is that there's also a fairness
argument here because the whole point
around this is It's on HRA owned land
that we've been installing the uh
parking and I think if if highways were
to uh subsidize only HRA tenants then
you would also have a fairness argument
for people who are in private housing or
private housing Estates who don't have
that same opportunity so I don't think I
can support the amendment uh in its
current form for that reason it doesn't
strike me as being the fairest it would
set a precedent and you know be bluntly
absolutely acutely honest that the
County Council does not have the funding
to deal with every single parking issue
across the whole County and I think but
the district does have funding through
the HRA to deal with issues where
parking is is most acute and where we
have uh residents who are regularly
complaining to us as elected members and
asking us to do more you know we can we
can really debate all the ideology
around whether H it's fair to use H
money for this that or the other but the
reality is I think residents want us to
do something practicable that actually
makes a difference to their life and
this is a really important um and good
possible way of doing that so I can't
support the amendment uh for those
reasons and I'll come back later to some
of counc ading stringer's comments about
the original substantive motion if
that's okay
sh you Council Giller just just to pick
up on a few of those points chair
obviously um if this amendment is passed
and becomes a substantive motion and
that's passed it doesn't Commit This
Council to actually doing anything other
than to review it so um the uh
consideration of a loan system I I have
some concerns about that as well if if I
were to vote for this I don't believe
I'm telling the council to do it I'm
just telling them to consider it so that
the officers can look into it and then
give proper advice so that a a proper
decision can be taken on on advice
um as regards to just going from the
situation that we've got at the moment
where we provide off street parking away
from properties scheme a as it were to a
completely different scheme which this
seems to be proposing where we just go
to providing um off street parking for
people on their own
drives it doesn't have to be black or
white I think some in some areas that is
the right thing to do in some areas it
isn't the right thing to do and I think
that's where the need for both
authorities to work together is
important I I get everything that
Council of Dale says and I think we'll
be having this debate on Wednesday
morning as well about in another place
but but I think I I would support this I
think the County Council you know you
come with a suggestion that it's the job
of this Council to do everything it can
to improve the lives of the residents
and that's true of this Council as it is
as true of any other Council and and and
therefore I'm prepared to support this
we'll put it to the County Council see
what they say and then let the cabinet
go away consider everything that's
considered in there if they can come up
with a scheme that works with loans I'm
prepared to entertain that and consider
it but if they come back and say there's
all these problems with it then
obviously I don't think it will get
through the through the appropriate
decision-making poers here thank you
Council Jill I think we've all been
distracted by the fact we've been
declared Idol and they're going to
switch us off
oh I resemble that
REM so I'm sure somebody technical will
be looking at that so we're in the
meantime councilor Hancock thank you um
to be truthful this is this is one in
principle support I either way because
we the key thing here is we can't let
anything lapse we've made this decision
as a council and we need to deliver on
it um I do support most of the amendment
I do have an issue with that loan thing
but actually for once in my life I agree
with councelor
Jill that that yes it is something for
consideration down the line we don't
have to accept a decision there and then
I do think highways have got a role to
play but I don't think we should be
conditional on that irrespective of
whether we get money from them or not we
still need to plow ahead with the 280
and hopefully more that we've already
put aside for it um I do take on board
what um what Frank said with regard to
the environmental things but we've also
got to look at what's real and what's
happening right now and obviously work
towards that in the future but we've
also got to deliver against against
people's needs right now so I I think
the amended version is better um and I
will support the amendment but
irrespective of whether the amendment
goes through or not I will be supporting
supporting the motion outrightly um but
yeah I have concerns over that loan
issue thank you any other
comments if not can I come back to
councelor Burkin then you reserved your
right to reply as a seconder thank you
chair just to say that um yeah I support
the uh the idea of the motion from
Council Dale but I think the amendment
that Council of AR is proposing just
takes it out bit further and will enable
us to to progress with this idea here
and and make benefits for people across
the district thank you and Council
Barker your right of
reply yeah thanks for that yeah I think
think a lot of what I've said in my
introduction as well uh we're reviewing
it because it's it's not as
straightforward as we we hoped I think
or you hope the the administration prior
and I think one of the considerations is
is right what what Frank says one of the
considerations in this and I think it
happened in uh in renish were it where
where it we thought oh let's put some
parking places there and all the people
that haven't got gas said no we don't
want to lose that green space so you've
got to balance that off with with the
provision of extra parking so it's all
got to be reviewed that the the uh the
complexity of trying to fund it out of
HRA money is and I'm sure Jane used to
say this at the audit committee uh every
time we we brought this up that there's
there's some legalities around that if
youve only you know only 50% of council
tenant Council housers and and the H
funding it all is that right so it's all
up in mix we're not discounting it uh
and I think uh I think it's something
like I've said and the the the motion
the amended motion spells it out that we
can chuck all that into mix uh and I
accept every estate could deal with more
car parking whether we like it or
not uh and there should be more buses or
or whatever but it it it's not
straightforward to pay for that and
where you put it there's technical
issues around building of uh services
and all that it's not not every bit of
Green Space can be a car park for lots
of reasons uh so we're not discounting
it it's there in the motion uh and and
again if the county count Council can
can match fund this that would be a
great bonus so I've already moved the uh
the amended motion you have so we're now
voting on the amendment put forward by
councilor Barker so if we could move to
the vote please this to vote to accept
the amendment yeah
yes okay so let's move the
results that's it the amendment is
passed and therefore becomes the
substantive
motion so we're back to the substantive
motion which is now the amendment that
we've just
agreed any comments now on the
substantive
motion I Council Q put you with a second
of the original motion which is now
substantive motion do you want to pass a
comment yeah thanks chair um I have got
to declare a bit of an interest because
I think we're about to be writing to
myself so I look forward to that times
I've written to myself and myself a St
stiff
warning I think I think just to address
a couple of the points throughout the
debate I think in terms of uh the car
you know the principle of car parking
provision I I think we all support
public transport you know in this County
we've received 51.5 million
in terms of specific bus funding you
know over the coming years and that's
something we're all working to try and
improve but we've got to be realistic
that some people need cars in our rural
district and they need access to
vehicles and that's that's not an anti-
environmental measure and some of the
some of the tenants that have have
raised this issue with me as well it's
not green space that they want to put a
driveway on it's sort of a half slabbed
thing but they can't quite Park on it
because it's not safe to do so so it's
it's not an environment Al aspect so I
don't really sort of buy into that part
of the argument and then just in the in
terms of the second thing I think we
will support the the now amended motion
whilst not supporting the amendment but
I do think it has confused and conflated
actually the principle behind this
motion which was aimed at sort of
council hous and specifically at tenants
rather than at just parking issues in
general because it was looking at what
this Council can focus on in terms of um
tenants and the issues that tenants and
Estates have with with Parky and we've
already touched on that earlier today in
relation to the mickley question so bit
disappointed by the amendment but you
know I think overall would still support
this motion because I think it we we
should be focusing on on getting the
parking strategy going again so let's
see how we can do that thank you
councelor
Dale yeah thank you chair not not much
more to add um to what councilor CIT
said I think just in response to
councelor adlington stringer's points I
mean lovely bit of idealism but um you
know you know we live in the real world
and our residents quite rightly expect a
bit of support to be able to deal with
issues like parking problems we we've
heard from him that that for some reason
a parking space is necessarily bad for
the climate but we obviously have
electric vehicles there are uh permeable
surfaces for these sorts of things they
don't have to be tarmac uh you know
there's even Solutions like Grass Grass
Creek for example um so I don't think we
should solely be thinking about the
foxes when um you know we're making
policy decisions like these it's
definitely a factor don't get me wrong
you know we absolutely need to consider
the environment but you know we have to
live in the real world here and and
focus on solutions that makes life
better for our residents and I think the
same can be said about the buses issue
absolutely you know in on Utopia it'd be
nice to be able to get on and off a bus
to even come to these meetings but we
don't live there we live in the real
world so um yeah great thank you chair
to thank you so we're we're going to
vote on the motion now which is the the
one that was the amendment is now the
actual substantive motion so just to be
clear about that so if we move to the
vote
please thank you and if we could move to
the
result that is carried thank you so item
13 there's no chair's urgent business so
item 14
I move that the public be excluded from
the meeting during the discussion of the
following items of business to avoid the
disclosure to them of exempt information
as defined in paragraphs 1 2 3 and five
part one of schedule 128 The Local
Government Act 1972 as amended by the
local government access to information
variation order 2006 do we have a second
there yes thank you Council moley all
those in favor by show of
hands that's carried so the public is
now